an ongoing crisis and the tragic loss
have affected the pawn star's family
Rick Harrison has finally opened up
about what happened on January 19th 2024
Pawn star's lead Rick Harrison's son
Adam passed away he was 39 years old
while initial reports suggested an
overdose details at the time were scarce
however Rick Harrison has confirmed to
TMZ that the cause of death have been a
fenal overdose Harrison told TMZ yes I
can confirm died from a fentanyl
overdose the fentanyl crisis in this
country must be taken more seriously it
seems it it's just flowing over the
borders and nothing is being done about
it we must do better as TMZ also notes
the Harrison family previously released
a statement asking they be given time
amongst themselves to Grapple with this
devastating news it said our family is
extremely saddened by the death of Adam
we ask for privacy as we grieve his loss
fans of Pawn Stars know that while Rick
Harrison's family is fairly active in
his business including his sons Corey
and Jake Adam Harrison did not appear on
the History Channel series before the
show began airing in 2009 Adam was
reportedly involved in the family
business however according to his
brother Cory he later branched out and
pursued a career as a plumber living his
life independently and avoiding the
nearly inescapable Fame that comes with
appearing on such a hit television
series while fans and Friends of the
Harrison family certainly respecting
their wishes for privacy at this time
there was still an outpouring of support
on social media regarding Adam
Harrison's tragic passing when Rick
Harrison posted an Instagram tribute to
his late son fans responded to the post
with well wishes radio host Joe Pags
wrote in a comment sorry to hear about
this Rick sending prayers actor Amelia
Rivera known for his roles in Flamin H
and Mayan's MC paid his respects as well
writing rest in peace my condolences to
you and the familiar Donald Trump Jr son
of former president Donald Trump also
responded to the post simply writing I'm
so sorry man it wasn't just famous
figures who turned up to show their
support for Rick fans of the show also
offered their condolences with one
person writing I am so sorry for your
loss Rick too many of our children are
taken by the disease of addiction Cory
Harrison who was just one year older
than his brother also took to Instagram
to post a tribute with a picture of the
pair when they were younger as Rick
Harrison noted in his statement to TMZ
the ongoing fenol and opioid addiction
crisis in the United States is nothing
short of horrific according to the
National Institute on drug abuse death
rates from overdoses have been steadily
increasing in recent years we're in a
crisis where they don't even really have
an
answer as a result of that more and more
people are going to die because of that
it's not surprising that pop culture has
tried to pack this devastating situation
whether these projects approach the
subject head-on or create some sort of
allegorical narrative who lose dop sck
tackles the battle against Peru farmer
and their marketing of oxy content
Netflix say painkiller also discusses
Perdue but directly adapts its story
from Patrick Ren Keefe's New Yorker
article the family that built an Empire
of pain and Barry me's book painkiller
an Empire of Deceit and the origin of
America's opioid epidemic which in on
the Sackler family even in the horror
genre Mike Flanagan addresses the
sackers in The Fall of the House of user
modeling the fictional Usher family
after the sacas and showing just how
their corporate greed led to widespread
addiction and tragic death it's awful to
see yet another promising life cut short
in real life when it comes to Adam
Harrison's sudden
[Music]
passing